foreign
do we need to keep the idea at least of
a fear of everything alive in order to
keep faith in this idea of scientific
progress and before anyone shouts at me
about scientific progress I'm just the
messenger
I'll let them take the blame what do you
think well I mean a lot of motivational
for why I've been running this blog and
wrote that wrote this book is it exactly
I think you know what
what happened in theoretical physics
starting around after Hawking starting
after 1980 was was something actually
quite dangerous because you know my
analysis of the problems that we're
hitting are is different but I think the
problem that I see happening is that we
see kind of a
kind of a pathology of the scientific of
the scientific method so the modern
science has this whole kind of apparatus
of of how you get jobs how you get
grants how you do all this and and it
really the the apparatus for how we
um provide incentives for people about
what to think about and what to work on
is really complete turns out to be
completely wrong I think for the kinds
of problems the field is facing in the
in the past we used to have you know
somebody would turn on a new accelerator
they would produce all these unexpected
new particles the theorists would then
immediately everybody would compete to
figure out what these new particles were
and write 10 papers in a few months and
so every
the field was really driven by this new
experimental information and it was very
very fadish but it made progress and
what's happened is that the experiments
have not been telling us anything really
unexpected and so but there's still this
the sociology of how you do science
which is demands that you
you continually have this novelty you
can easily have a new paper you
continually do all this and it ended up
producing you know a lot of what's
happened with supersymmetry and Grand
unified theories and super string theory
is they were kind of generated by the
the necessity of the way the scientific
research is organized and and they
really simply were ideas that don't that
didn't didn't work and instead of but
but people that you know once people
have written 100 papers about something
they're not going to admit that this
doesn't work and you and and this is
actually potentially quite damaging I
think to the extent that people look and
see these TV programs or whatever about
the glories of string theory and then
later find out oh wait a minute this was
all kind of nonsense this is actually
really you know has real dangers for for
the way people um you know respect or
think about science can I come to you
Becky because I think I can't remember
which of the the
creators of quantum mechanics said the
short version is science progressed his
funeral by funeral is that pooling Max
Planck Max plan thank you
um
so do your students need to believe in a
fear of everything to have an idea that
they can make progress or the opposite
well I would say the opposite and I
would say the opposite because you want
them to have some chance to contribute
you know students can do amazing things
my kids put a payload up in space and
fed data to CERN and NASA they use CERN
technology and did amazing things and
you want them to feel that they can do
that and you also teach a lot in science
but most of science is being wrong
actually that you're not always getting
the answer and you know you're doing
experiments and perhaps they don't work
and that's all scientific uh experience
and that's one of the strengths of
science that it could admit say super
symmetry that it's wrong one of my
colleagues spent this whole PhD doing
um on City symmetry at CERN and of
course nobody seems to have got any
evidence but yet so I would say that
actually you know Perhaps Perhaps the
focus because he's wrong I was reading
um about the talk Martin Reese did to
the RSA just recently and you know
perhaps it we should more Focus about
how science should have a vision for
improving the planet saving the planet
sorting out you know what's going on in
the world rather than this sort of
rather to me now it seems a bit you know
who who decided that surely we've got
different priorities here well I mean
I'd like to say it's not just physics
and Richard Horton the editor of the
Lancer I think it was in 2014 wrote a
paper saying 50 of biomedical science is
wrong and he was the editor of the
Lancet so it's not just physics
how do we get out of that I mean
what do we do what do we say to students
to to to to get them to understand that
they can somehow step outside but
they're still they're not gonna suddenly
see the universe the way it is because
you on one hand you're saying step
outside the Paradigm but you're not
saying and then you'll see the world
clearly so how do you put it to them I I
agree it it it's a bit tricky I mean my
suggestion was that we think of the
world as open we stop thinking it as a
thing that we might have an answer to
not a theme we somehow think of it as
being you know what's the answer to the
university like seven and a half here
it's it's that it's already divided that
there's it's out there we're cracking a
crossword puzzle there's the problem of
human knowledge is is to crack the
crossword puzzle well you know before
you start that we're not going to crack
it are we I mean it's not that you know
we've just had 10 000 years of of human
civilizations that's that's got closer
and we're just in a little bit we're
going to crack it I mean you know we're
not going to do that
um
so if if we did we'd close down our
universities
oh it's all over now there's nothing
more to do that's what they said didn't
they yeah and it's it's obviously it's
obviously a fantasy that's that's not
our relationship to knowledge uh or
relation of the relationship of
knowledge to the world it enables us to
do things we can do all sorts of things
we couldn't do before and we need to
continue to try and do that but just to
to the previous conversation we're
talking about The Theory of Everything I
am in favor as I mentioned at the
beginning I am in favor of pursuing the
attempt to provide an overall Theory so
in one sense I like the idea of yes we
need to try and provide an overall
Theory and why do I think that I think
that it's because it's only by trying to
make your overall model that you realize
the bits that don't work
it's only by having your overall
cosmological theory that starts to think
actually this inflation Cosmic inflation
stuff doesn't really make sense we've
got a problem about you know where's the
edge of the uh Universe we've got a
problem about you know the the
mathematics of the all of those all of
those bits are part of the overall
picture and you need that overall
picture to identify what doesn't work
but that doesn't mean to say there's a
right one around the corner it just
means that any model that you perceive
proceed with will always generate those
problems but we're just trying to make
our models better and be able to do
things we can't do at the moment and the
exciting bit about all of this now you
know I do think there is an exciting
because most people feel this oh the
loss of reality is is gonna is a real
problem I don't I think it's exciting
because it's the idea that we can catch
sight of other ways of holding the world
which will enable us to do things that
we can't do at the moment and that's
fantastic idea your lesson favor for
answers and better mistakes is what you
want I think certainly we certainly want
to find new mistakes
you'd love to make a new mistake rather
than just repeating oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah if we could that's kind of our
problem is that we don't we haven't
admitted up to our current mistakes
we're not making any new ones this is
exactly our problem right now yes
because I mean for a while it looked
like you were being edged into the
defender of The Theory of Everything But
then I'm thinking yes but you're the man
who has bashed away at String Theory
when it had pretension to being the
answer everything more than anybody else
yeah yeah yeah but but very specific
specifically because it was I mean there
are things that I and many people could
see you know there's a TV program saying
oh this is a huge success so this is
wonderful this is doing all this great
stuff and I and many other people looked
and said well no it actually doesn't
this doesn't work and that doesn't work
that doesn't work and and you know that
so that relationship between the kind of
public reality and what I was seeing was
actually going on was was what had drove
me to these extreme efforts of this blog
and the book but uh yes but it yeah it's
a separate issue of you know is there
I'm in some sense an agreement with the
strength there is I actually had had
lunch with a string theorist in Oxford
last week and we found that one
he wouldn't mind Joe conlon and but he
uh you know and I I find that we ended
up agreeing on on almost everything you
know except very specifically prospects
for certain kinds of ideas that you know
that I would claim there's a good
argument that this couldn't go nowhere
and he's devoting his life to trying to
do it
um and I think we ended up that's not
what we really discussed because that
would not be a very fruitful discussion
I think but um other than that
you know I'm not
in terms of goals I'm I'm unfortunately
kind of in agreement with this with the
string there is it's a but
trying to understand that there is a
there is a fundamental difference I
think between the two of you in the
sense that if I've understood right you
think there is an an objective reality
out there maybe that only God knows what
it is but it's there and I think you're
saying there may be something out there
but God's never going to tell us and our
relationship with it is always
relational it's always it and us
I think I'm not going to be tempted to
say what is out there because any
description I give is going to be
perspectival it's going to be another
model so but and in that sense I go
along with uh Hawking's uh position he
called it model theoretic realism I'm
not quite sure why he used the word
realism it seems to me that that makes
out that it's rather something rather
than different from what I I he seems to
be arguing to me which is that we just
have to realize that
we operate within Frameworks and they
are our reality you know we can't break
through that reality to to find the
ultimate stuff but there's lots of
constraint on our models we can't we we
see the effect of all of the stuff out
there in terms of how we understand it
we understand it through our model so
it's not like
we're just lost in this network of
um an idealist world of making up
anything you want you've got loads of
constraint but it's just you can't work
out what what it is that's constraining
you because you're stuck in your model
you can't get through you know I thought
the quote I heard of Hawking is just
right you know there's no there's no
um model independent test
how are you going to do this you've got
to have a theory to look to see what's
happened
where does mathematics come into this
because I I have a feeling that that's
at least part of your hesitation to
agree with Hillary because I can see you
nodding at some things he says but
something's holding you back
yeah because it was a bit again it we
talked a lot about this in other
discussion the question is you know my
position I I've been partly in the
physics departments partly a math
department so I've been thinking about
this relationship of mathematics and
physics most most of my life and and and
just continually seeing as I learn more
about the subject these deeper and
deeper
um relationships between between the two
subjects so this is part of
you know my resistance idea well this is
just a model because I mean I I on the
the mathematician in me is actually
looking at
um
seeing all sorts of very very different
areas of mathematics which is a kind of
a completely different story than and
how we interact with the world and
seeing that at a deep level these
structures are coming together between
our our model of reality and kind of
deep mathematical structures and so
maybe I've I think Lee's moment accuses
me of being a mathematical Mystic and so
I so I I can't
anyway I've become more and more of the
feeling that there is there is this kind
of Deep
thing going on there which is only we
only very partially understand and and
this you know
maybe you can maybe you can say that you
know thinking that this exists and is is
some just good to do because it's going
to encourage me maybe in in positive
directions or maybe it really does exist
but whatever it is this is a motivation
Becky I wanted to come to you because
there's a sort of a dark side to the the
idea that there's an objective reality
and our models are getting closer to it
because you can end up saying look I'm
objectively right and you are just
objectively wrong and especially if I've
got a PhD from somewhere and you haven't
and there is that sort of authoritarian
side to it isn't it we don't want to
overplay it but it is there well yeah I
would agree and I would agree that how
are we ever going to get out into new
models unless we have a different
education or possibilities of acceptable
science within the whole education
system because that's what you do and
what you know we're talking about bigger
and bigger accelerators and that's one
particular sort of obsession to get
higher and higher and higher energies
and actually perhaps that's not the way
to go but that seems to be the Orthodox
thing now and you sort of think about
you know uh that whole idea of an
objective reality when I was in Chicago
I worked with Bob Garrosh and I swear
that he lived in multiple universes he
was like one of those parallel universes
people and you sort of think we've lost
some of that sort of uh one that sort of
wow you know because if you're just
stuck in the asset model you know
actually if you think about implications
of quantum mechanics it's phenomenal and
that could spark different models and
different ways that we perhaps could
think of students and US interacting
with the world in a way which might
encourage sort of innovation and new
ideas new approaches
um it sort of brings us to the the
third theme to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas